[Music]
hey wisecrack
helen here today we're going to talk
about a film that explores the beautiful
dynamics of a happy
loving family with zero trauma to speak
of
just kidding we're talking about
hereditary a movie that makes
thanksgiving at the bluth house
look like a norman rockwell painting
hereditary immediately established
director ari astor as a bonafide horror
maestro
but it's worth asking what makes a movie
about your typical family
one of the most disturbing horror films
in recent memory
the answer has nothing to do with naked
cults demons or dark arts
and everything to do with your dna don't
worry we'll explain in this wisecrack
edition on
hereditary and of course spoilers ahead
but first
since we can't count on paymon for our
riches we need you
at least until we find a suitable host
for two bucks a month you can get
ad-free access to all of wisecrack's
videos before anyone else that's like
two spicy potato soft tacos which she
won't be able to eat anymore anyway
for a little more and still
substantially less than your whole
family dying
you can also hang out with the wisecrack
team and other patrons on our exclusive
patron discord
click here or go to patreon.comwisecrack
to check it out
and now back to the show hereditary
centers around
artist annie graham who is sort of in
mourning over the death of her estranged
mother before she can even process that
loss though
her daughter charlie is killed in a free
car accident while her son is at the
wheel
[Applause]
as annie's whole world subsequently
crumbles a mysterious woman teaches her
to perform a seance that channels
charlie's spirit
and that's where everything goes a
little off the rails
eventually we learned that annie's dead
mom was part of a totally banana's pagan
cult that is looking for a vessel for
its favorite demon
by the end pretty much everyone is
beheadedly worshipping charlie spirit
which has been planted into peter's body
so why is it so scary well partially
because it contains stuff like this
but horror films that really shake us
tend to anchor even their most
supernatural scares in our real life
fears
in hereditary's case the clue is in the
name
it's the story of a family doomed to
misery by their lineage
while most of us probably don't have to
worry about our grandmothers being
secret occultists
the idea that we might suffer for our
parents sins is pretty universal
and that universality has everything to
do with hereditary's scare factor
see some of the most unhinged events of
the film can be explained by the concept
of repression one of the cornerstones of
sigmund freud's psychoanalytic theory
repression is the process by which the
conscious mind is shielded from feelings
and thoughts which are too painful to
acknowledge
these buried emotions are left to fester
unresolved and often manifest themselves
in occasionally
alarming ways like uh this
indeed annie is a case study in
repression
her life has been littered with
tragedies that she is unable to fully
confront
in her eulogy for her mother annie tries
to find nice words to say
but inadvertently ends up stressing how
emotionally unavailable and controlling
she was
my mother was a very secretive and
private woman
she had private rituals private friends
private anxieties annie's true feelings
bubble beneath the surface
too repressed to be articulated and too
powerful to be let go
this is pretty blatant foreshadowing
annie doesn't know how sinister her
mother's private rituals were
or that the strange faces she sees in
the pews are actually members of ellen's
cult
right from the beginning the things that
the graham family hides are sowing the
seeds of their own destruction
annie's repression makes honest
communication with those closest to her
difficult if not impossible
it gets too cold come back in
i just need to sleep the only place
she'll talk about her traumatic past
is at a grief support group full of
strangers even then
she's completely detached reeling off
the laundry list of horrifying things
that occurred during her childhood
in an almost casual way she didn't have
an easy life
she had did which became extreme at the
end
and dementia i'm not finished yet
there's more my older brother had
schizophrenia and when he was 16 he
hanged himself in my mother's bedroom
and of course his suicide note blamed
her accusing her of putting people
inside him so
that was my mom's life it's notable that
annie finishes this speech by distancing
herself from the narrative
these are her mother's traumas not hers
even when acknowledging her family's
history she's unwilling to accept it as
part of her story
annie's not unique in her inability to
deal with tragedy during what freud
calls the first use of the
psychoanalytic approach
the patient anna oh was encouraged to
make poetical compositions that could
offer her relief from her chronic
anxiety
using art to express what she couldn't
say out loud fittingly
annie's art functions in the same way
she makes miniature doll houses that
recreate her traumatic life events
however it's not accurate to call
annie's creepy model home
therapeutic freud emphasized that it's
not enough to artistically depict
traumatic events
the patient also has to engage with the
emotions attached
even as annie recreates her past traumas
in minute detail
she refuses to acknowledge the emotional
payload they carry
something which becomes ghoulishly clear
after she creates a bleak depiction of
charlie's death
and peter's role in it it's not about
him oh no
it's a neutral view of the accident but
any strange behavior is ultimately
understandable she's coping with her
trauma
all on her own when tragedy strikes we
hope to lean on the people around us for
support
often relying on a stable familial
structure to hold us together
however many modern familial units are
really not set up to deal with such
severe emotions
in fact many aren't really set up to
deal with emotions at
all don't you swear at me you little sh
don't you ever
raise your voice at me i am your mother
and that brings us to what really makes
hereditary
so scary family in these surprisingly
whimsical best-seller
families and how to survive them dr
robin skinner and british comedian
john cleese elucidate why talking openly
with our loved ones can feel so
impossible and its lessons become all
too relevant and hereditary which is all
about people who are fundamentally
unable to survive their own family
they're like pawns in this
horrible hopeless machine the book
centers on the premise that most of our
attitudes and characteristics are
grounded in our original family
experience and relationships
and argues that repressed people tend to
form family units that are also
repressive
i.e the grams annie and her husband
steve
lie to one another rather than dealing
with upsetting emotions
she hides the fact that she is going to
a grief support group and he hides the
fact that her mother's grave has been
desecrated
this chronic inability to communicate
soon comes back to haunt them
what was it
just some billing crap
okay well i'm uh i'm gonna go see a
movie the perpetual secrecy that hangs
over their relationship
leads to mistrust and even paranoia as
when steve accuses annie herself of
being responsible for desecrating the
grave
you took up the grave it was you wasn't
it
what all those nights you were
pretending to go to the movies
here the staggeringly toxic results of
family-wide repression become abundantly
clear
and the same is true for the gram's
children after the grandmother's funeral
annie and steve try to prompt charlie
and peter to open up about their
feelings
to no avail not surprising given their
parents reluctance to honestly voice
their own emotions
charlie is repressed to the point where
she barely talks responding to emotional
stimuli with a strange
and truly terrifying clicking noise
instead
she is particularly unable to express
anything negative or confrontational
when forced into an argument
she simply concedes that's okay and we
learned that her practice of suppressing
emotions started very early
you never cried as a baby
you know that peter on the other hand
buries his emotions under a cloud of
marijuana smoke
numbly sleep walking through much of the
day his parents do the same
popping prescription pills to blank out
their own feelings
so what happens when you make four
deeply repressed people share a home
you know stuff like this
the grams are completely cut off from
one another emotionally
compartmentalized into separate rooms as
if in one of annie's miniatures
even in the wake of ellen's death the
family is more concerned with how they
are
supposed to feel than how they actually
feel
should i be sad you should be whatever
you are
it'll come as a result the grams are
totally unequipped to deal with
charlie's death
which is made gallingly clear by peter's
decision to cocoon himself in bed
leaving his parents to discover her body
he is so unable to process the trauma
and his role in it
that he simply shuts down in an
emotionally healthy family
the trauma of charlie's death though
intolerably painful
could be the impetus for self-reflection
and even growth
in life and how to survive it another
book written by the dr comedian duo
skinner explains that the healthier
people are the more they are willing to
admit to their limitations
and so the more open they are to the
possibility of improvement
but the grams were emotionally unhealthy
even before the tragedy
in its wake they are unable to reckon
with the pain or even
ask for help in the rare moments when
the grams do talk about their feelings
it gets ugly fast in one exchange annie
projects many of her own problems onto
peter
or refusing to recognize them in herself
even at this
explosive moment she continues to
repress her feelings
specifically her guilt about charlie's
death i
can't accept and i can't forgive
because nobody admits anything they've
done
what about you mom she didn't want to go
to the party
so why was she there but annie's
inability to get in touch with her
feelings
isn't some kind of moral failing it was
somewhat
inevitable skinner talks about how many
of our painful experiences
are ultimately a simple consequence of
family history
over which no one had any control for
the grams
this is certainly true their grandmother
ultimately dooms them
but not just because of her pagan
machinations
rather her most potent legacy is her
emotional detachment
which continues to drive her family
apart even after she's gone
in this sense the grams are beset by a
very real
family curse they each inherit the
repressive tendencies of their parents
which causes their trauma to fester
until it's out of control
as annie explains in her eulogy her
mother was an emotionally distant person
unable to offer her the love or support
that she needed fittingly
claise argues that many of our problems
are really childhood difficulties
that we failed to resolve when we were
young and consequently carry around with
us
in our adult lives it's no surprise then
that annie inherited a complex
damaged idea of what it was to be a
mother which in turn instilled a
deep fear of becoming one she represses
that fear though
burying it in her unconscious so it can
only manifest in her dreams
i didn't feel like a mother both her
dreamed confession and her murderous
sleepwalking
are byproducts of these unwanted
unthinkable ideas
annie remains unable to accept them as
parts of herself
even after she almost burns her children
alive she refuses to admit the severity
of the situation
and i was standing there with a box of
matches and an empty can of paint
thinner
and i woke myself up striking the match
which also woke peter up and he started
to scream
to do so would mean acknowledging the
part of her that wanted to harm her
children
shattering her already tenuous maternal
identity
i mean i was just as shocked as he was
and it was
impossible to convince them that it was
just sleepwalking
unable to process her childhood traumas
she replicates them
she unwittingly neglects her children
even giving charlie to ellen in a
desperate attempt to win the approval
she still craves
i didn't let her anywhere near me when i
had my first my son which is why
i gave her my daughter who she
immediately stabbed her hooks into
and in turn she creates kids who are
just like her
repressing their traumatic childhood
experiences to preserve an image of
normalcy
peter and charlie can't confront the
idea that their mother tried to kill
them or
in charlie's case functionally gave her
away any more than annie can
so the whole family continues stumbling
forward in willful ignorance
and this is where the freaky
supernatural elements of the film
become so important the family's
increasingly creepy experiences
are symbolic of their dysfunction as a
result they are blinded to all the signs
that something sinister is brewing
even as they each individually notice
markings and apparitions
they are unable to communicate about
them for fear that their sanity will be
called into question
in fact ellen's pagan tendencies only go
unnoticed in the first place because of
how distant she and annie are
when she dies all her secrets are there
to be discovered in a box in the attic
but no one finds them until it is too
late fittingly the fraught emotional
associations annie has with her mother
ensure she won't do the work of sorting
her belongings
or her own emotions this lays the
groundwork for ellen's creepy friend
joan to enact the later stages of their
plan
sure they have hundreds of years of
demonic knowledge and mystical energy on
their side
but their plan would be a non-starter if
annie had taken a brief flick through
her mom's old things
the family's mal adjustment makes them
vulnerable in the first place
after drawing annie in joan offers her a
basic psychological defense
denial if annie can believe in the
seance then she doesn't have to really
face the fact that charlie is dead
doesn't have to reckon with her
involvement in her death or reconcile
that with her fear of motherhood
so long as charlie isn't dead that can
all remain buried
you didn't kill her annie
what she isn't gone
but the seance also serves a larger
psychological purpose
dr skinner talks about how feeling
plugged into a meaningful cosmic system
gives people a greater psychological
balance and stability
and that's exactly what jones mysticism
offers annie
her home life her whole world has been
shattered
and joan offers her a way to piece it
back together to reconstruct her family
of course it is not inherently
supernatural to believe that some part
of the people we lose
lives on in us but sometimes it's not
exactly the parts we would like
several studies about transgenerational
trauma have suggested that the
descendants of those who undergo great
suffering
might carry the psychological markers of
it themselves
potentially leaving them more vulnerable
to ptsd
anxiety depression and other conditions
one of the first studies into this
phenomenon was undertaken by canadian
psychiatrist
vivian m rakoff who found that the
children of holocaust survivors
showed uncommonly high rates of
psychological distress
rakoff's findings in subsequent studies
give evidence to the
idea that trauma is passed down not only
through the influence of our parents
behavior
but through their genetic material in
this way ellen passes her own trauma
onto annie
and annie passes it on to peter and
charlie each member of the family has
developed their own repressive
mechanisms
to ensure that their demons are never
exercised
eventually those demons will destroy
them
the supernatural forces at play
naturally parallel the severe mental
illness which runs in the
family demonic possession and curses
after all
have historically been used as
explanations for mental health problems
that could not be otherwise understood
ellen's husband and son both killed
themselves as a result of schizophrenia
or psychotic depression
although her son's claimed that she was
putting voices inside him
raises the question of whether she was
experimenting with demon raising
even back then through these acts of
violence the family's self-destructive
legacy is passed on to each member
dooming them to the same bloody fate as
those who came before
much of who we are is hereditary it's
why so many of us can probably relate to
annie and her family
feeling somewhat doomed to repeat the
past and one day turn into our parents
ultimately the thing which locks the
graham family into their fate isn't
ancient rights or mysterious ruins but
their own inability to process the
trauma they have undergone
they suppress and suppress and suppress
it until it finally
explodes the violence which comes
exploding out
is filled with darkly poetic repetitions
and reversals
annie beheads herself in a gory
imitation of charlie's death
her nighttime fantasies of burning a
family member alive
come true when steve goes up in flames
repression and trauma lock them into a
cycle and their tortured family history
seems doomed to repeat itself
until they have all been destroyed but
what do you guys think are we all doomed
to repeat our family's dysfunction
let us know in the comments big thanks
to our patrons for your support
light that subscribe button on fire and
as always
thanks for watching peace
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you